had Blair not experienced this like near
death experience do you think this would
ever have been even an inkling to delve
into this I think he's always wanted to
build this it's been in him for a really
really long time but I think having that
opportunity to say listen let's just do
what we want for one year one year where
we just go to the wall and do exactly
what we want to do I was teaching joy
and laughter coaching I teach laughter
yoga and it took a long time for people
in Barry to take that seriously believe
it or not and I loved doing what I was
doing and when you give yourself
permission to follow your passion just
even for one year I think everybody
should get to do that because what
happens is and I think we've all seen it
people who go through their jobs wishing
that they weren't there they're unhappy
they're toxic and that's a sad way to
live your life I mean I'm looking
forward to and Blair always says that
i'm looking forward to cutting that
six-figure check to the first author
that hits a big on our platform because
that could happen and that would be
amazing like these diamonds in the rough
that haven't been discovered that they
couldn't get published couldn't land
that screenplay deal but they created
this game that everybody loved so that's
what drives us right I think there's so
much pressure for adults especially at a
certain age to have reached a certain
income level and they only want to
associate with people of that ilk
because they feel like that'll help them
and then okay this is who I am I'm great
and I think it's difficult for people to
say I'm going to cut back how has that
been for the two of you because I know
there's a lot of social pressure even if
you go into the market you feel it it's
this unspoken sort of elephant in the
room so as someone that's you know I'm
in the same boat that's why I yeah yeah
well I have purple hair and for the
longest time ever since I left my
conservative job back in 2010 the first
thing I did when I got off the plane
when we moved to San Francisco was
fuchsia cool big streak of fuchsia
because I could
and when we move to Dallas little old
ladies with tisk me I want to be me and
I want to be happy so I don't care if
you make a hundred thousand a year or
ten thousand a year if you're a good and
authentic person I want to get to know
you and I don't really care about Prada
or Gucci or anything like that I do
enjoy flying first class and I would
like to continue that but for that if I
can but it's not about those material
things don't tell me who you are as a
human being except that maybe maybe
you're able to afford that or maybe
you're sitting behind a mountain of debt
we don't know who people are based on
what lifestyle they're living and I know
a lot of unhappy people with huge
mortgages that if they just you know got
a little shack and did what they loved I
would much rather be that person right i
know there was a website a while back
especially when the recession was in
full swing and people are losing their
jobs and it was called something like
thank goodness i dot dot dot and some of
them were thank goodness i got cancer
because then i saw a life in a whole new
way that i wouldn't have let go of these
are all these notions of success that I
had that until I was facing that sort of
this could be it for me things change so
i think that's interesting and and have
you heard of others that have been in a
similar thing maybe it's not a death
sentence maybe they lost a job maybe
they so i think that you see a lot of
amazing resilience from people you know
and that's what got us through that
whole experience was gratitude so when i
do my public speaking bit so my joy and
laughter life I talk about gratitude you
know that day that he walked off his job
saved his life because the doctors
didn't know what was wrong with him they
finally tested him and it was like whoa
you know he was a couple weeks away from
dying because nobody knew what was wrong
with him so every single day has
something to be thankful for and I think
I remember writing that letter to
friends and family saying right here's
the minimum investment to help us build
this crazy dream and the money that
poured in that week was just so
incredible and there are people that can
support you financially or through
mentorship or just
being there and believing in new I think
that's yeah that's the thing that really
keeps you going and it really needs to
be we as a society need to be focused on
gratitude and really tapping into what
matters to you you know don't go and
build a video game studio or write a
script if you don't love it because your
lack of love will show up and people
people don't want people don't want that
it almost reminds me of the movie life
as a house with kevin kline on if you've
seen it but it's fantastic Oh fantastic
and he reaches that point where he's
pushed out of his job he finds out he
has a terminal illness or or could be
and and then just everything sort of
changes up believe it or not from there
reaching out to people for financial
assistance I'm sure there's a way to do
it that's a little more well-received
than others how did you to approach I
know you're in an interesting situation
where it was different but for those who
maybe they haven't been given that you
know you have this haha well you know
it's um I cashed up my retirement fund
when we move back to Canada cuz we were
in Texas when he when that happened cash
had my retirement fund and we put all of
our personal savings into making this
happen and for us when it came to asking
the friends and family for the
investment in the company it was a very
it was like a micro business plan here's
what we're doing here's the space in the
market here's the opportunity and quite
frankly I mean so many of them wrote a
check without even seeing a prototype
which really I think spoke to the
stability of our marriage and that they
know that we are solid people that we
could carry this through there's a lot
of people who I think entrepreneurship
is really self advocacy and that's the
thing that's missing amongst artists you
know you could write the best novel in
the world or the best screenplay in the
world but if you don't ever show that to
someone or get feedback or a mentorship
you're not going to grow as a beat as a
human being how do you expect for people
to root for you if you're not rooting
for yourself so being the hustler my job
is to well
talk up the company but also to really
be the company's advocate and I think
it's a lot easier to want to give
somebody money or support when they know
their stuff
you